[Music]
cj is in chattanooga hi cj welcome to
the ramsey show
hey how's it going guys better than we
deserve what's up
doing well my question is should we use
the potential student loan reimbursement
program to pay off our house i had uh
two or three student loans and that
would paid off in december 2020 it looks
like they may qualify potentially we'll
see how it all pans out but should i do
that
what's left on the mortgage
about thirty thousand dollars and how
much do you think you would get if you
got the forgiveness
uh probably about six or eight uh if
it's up to ten we'll have to see exactly
um
how what the requirements are for
the reimbursement program
so this isn't going to clear the
mortgage you just are saying should we
apply it to the mortgage
well we also have about 20 000 in
savings that we could use to pay off the
house as well that's not including our
emergency fund oh awesome why aren't you
using the 20 000 today to pay down the
mortgage
uh i have my first child coming uh
september 23rd
congrats just in case thank you thank
you smart yeah that makes sense
and uh we
i've been kind of tracking this to see
what's happening and it looks like the
student loan providers our servicers are
not writing checks what they're doing is
reinstating the balance back to 10 000
and then saying all right good luck hope
the government clears that balance so
that's what's actually happening right
now as far as i can tell but he's
talking about ones he's already paid off
that's what they're saying they would
cut him a check
so that's what that's what i've been
seeing is if you've already paid it off
during the pause they're saying you can
get a refund according to the us
department of education but the refund
doesn't actually there's no checks being
cut their student loan services are
saying your balance is zero we're going
to put it back to 10
and then the government can forgive that
10.
hopefully wow well that doesn't make
sense i know but where's the money go
he wouldn't get a check that way
there would be i don't i don't know how
that's going to pass that's not logical
i'm sorry i just applied logic to the
federal that is a report from someone
who contacted their student loan service
excuse me lord forgive me jesus yeah
okay um
no
i that's not that's not right george
something's wrong i hope not well i mean
that's not because that way the uh the
student loan
lender would get the money
yeah the question is where is this money
how are people going to get this money
back if they've already paid and we
don't know yet he's thinking he's
getting a check
um if he applies for it um
have you contacted your student loan
servicer
uh no yeah i don't know i mean nobody
knows it's all hearsay at this point
it's all it's all what might happen if
this crap goes through and if it's
declared legal instead of being an
executive order that which by the way
there's this thing called the
constitution that's going in the way and
um there's going to be lawsuits stopping
this and i don't know i don't know i i'm
i'm not worried about it i wouldn't
worry about it cj until it happens
uh because it might not uh
and
i've already caught enough crap on this
subject
nationally there i mean there's an
entire parade of dave ramsey haters out
there because i told people i think this
whole thing is absolutely horrendous and
bogus
i'm happy for people who get their loans
forgiven but when you take
300 billion dollars 300 000 million
of other people's debt and put it on the
back of the taxpayers it's just immoral
as hell
uh while you're continuing to make the
loans which is dishonest
if you keep making the loans it's
intellectually dishonest so i'm
i'm sitting here i'll just be very open
okay i'm sitting here trying to
put cj's shoes on and walk in them and
say what would i do if i was in his
shoes and i'm having trouble doing it
and that's not to slam you cj but i'm
having trouble doing it because i think
this whole thing is so bogus that to
actually receive the check from this
as like some kind of government benefit
after i've already paid off my loans it
just makes me want to puke
it makes me want to throw up i got a
little throw up in my mouth right now
and so it just um
yeah it just makes my blood boil i'd
continue on with the babies there's so
much wrong with it and um
there's a part of me cj that says you
already paid off your loan you ought to
just keep moving with your life dude
there's a part of me that says that
inside i understand the other side of it
i get it intellectually i'm just being a
bit emotional